you were you had like a a serious heart
surgery when you were 13. and I'm
wondering how impactful that was on just
kind of the formation of a world view
and I mean in had it had it had this
heart condition like uh hampered you
when you were growing up were you like
one of those kids that your mom and dad
were always
worried that
uh you were gonna get sick or something
yeah so
um that's really funny uh I remember
telling this story on Cone on one of my
first Conan appearances oh probably like
20 years ago yeah uh and you haven't
talked about it since never no no one's
ever brought it up
um no but uh it's yeah so it's an
interesting question
um I was diagnosed at Birth with uh with
basically a heart murmur which is
something a lot of people have and
they're they're they can often be benign
um but it's caused by some irregularity
in the shape of your arteries or in the
shape of your heart chambers or in the
valves themselves
um some irregularity I had a narrowing
like kind of an hourglass narrowing
um on my uh aorta and pulmonary arteries
and so
um
and so I had a kind of a double murmur
actually and uh and it was not a problem
when I was born it was just it was
something that was observed and noted
and my parents were told immediately and
they were very very worried but but we
had this amazing
um Pediatric Cardiologist who became a
dear dear family friend uh Dr plauth and
he
um
and and he basically kind of nurtured us
all the way through uh and and the the
prognosis at that time was he's fine you
know this kid is fine but just we're
just going to keep an eye on it yeah and
then there's a chance when he hits
puberty and has a growth spurt that the
uh the kind of relative
um difference in the deformity could
become problematic and and it did so
when I hit about 12
um they were seeing that the narrow
these narrowing parts were not growing
at the same rate as the rest of me so uh
so that so they came became worse
essentially could you feel a physical
effects of that yeah so most of my
childhood nothing at all you know I was
a very rambunctious active kid you know
tons of sports and and craziness
and uh and then I think around 11 12 I
just couldn't keep up in gym class the
same way like you know we'd be running
around a track or something and I was
always kind of towards the back of the
pack if not last and I
I didn't really I was I was very
frustrated by that but I but I didn't I
didn't notice that that there was any
problem I just didn't have the same
stamina yeah and around that time uh our
the my cardiologist Pediatric
Cardiologist was saying
yeah I think we're gonna let's start
talking about surgery because this is
gonna need we're gonna need to correct
this and so
it was a a long ramp into the surgery
about a year where we were talking about
it and and kind of Consulting with the
surgeon uh this amazing surgeon Willis
Williams uh who um has since passed away
but uh really like a remarkable uh
pediatric cardiac cardiologist surgeon
and
um and he so that that's all to say it
wasn't sudden it wasn't something that
was like oh my God he like wheel him
into the yeah the you know the operating
room right away it was it was this thing
that had been building and I'd had lots
of tests uh heart catheterizations which
are kind of these unpleasant tests where
they stick a camera up your
um uh up your
uh what's the artery in your thigh the
the big ephemeral yeah is that your
femoral yeah yeah yeah so they they uh
they go in through your thigh and they
put a camera they stick a camera all the
way up into your heart yeah and they can
get really good view of what's going on
and I'd had a few of those and
um and so they they had a really good
idea of what the problem was and exactly
how to fix it and
um and the surgeon was incredibly
confident and reassuring and so I think
we were all my family my parents and me
were all somewhat anxious but also
feeling fairly like this was an
inevitable thing and here we go we're
going in which is scheduled around
school like was it scheduled yeah so it
ruined your summer yeah well so it was
scheduled uh uh the first day of spring
break and so I went into surgery on I I
mean I think I went in on Monday and
then
um I was in the the you know intensive
care for a few days and then and then
the regular hospital for a few days and
then I was home uh after about eight
days
um recovering and I recovered very
quickly you know as a because I was just
a kid yeah a really active kid and
um and I was back at school like two
weeks later but but just sort of going
for like a couple of hours right and
then coming home and and the real worry
was not
um the the the most I think
the the what my cardiologist said was
the thing I'm most worried about is some
kid running by you in the hall and like
bumping into you yeah because your your
sternum is still healing right wow like
it's such an invasive operation and and
that's that's way more dangerous than
anything you're gonna do just to your
heart yeah actively yeah like your heart
is healing and everything's looking good
and then it was an incredibly successful
outcome I became a varsity swimmer on my
high school swim team oh wow and um and
you know went on to just yeah and I
still I see my cardiologist regularly
now and uh and it's it's still a really
great outcome that's great oh I'm so I
feel like I was really hoping for like
it made you you know like a dark
weakling yeah you know
was shunned by society and then decided
I'll get on The Daily Show yeah a lot of
rage yeah at the at the all these you
know the things that you can't control
it did give me a really powerful college
essay because you're filling out my
college applications and I just seen
Dead Poets Society and I was obsessed
with Carpe Diem and yeah you know this
is yeah so I just got a new lease on
life because I got this heart surgery
and I was told that that I would
probably not have lived past my early
20s wow uh and that and that I would
have declined pretty rapidly yeah from
the from that you know from my late
teens into my 20s and then died and so
knowing that
um uh you know I still was a just a
rambunctious bullheaded idiot kid and so
that none of that really sank in I don't
think kids can process that sort of no
like existential Insanity they no and I
mean thank God they can yeah you know
it's it's a yeah and your survival
mechanism totally and you're so
Invincible as a kid yeah um that but but
I did understand intellectually like oh
this is something I can I can spin into
a sure a good college essay and if it's
you know late on you you got to use it